[Música]
el peor escenario posible un apocalipsis
zombi como sobrevivirás tal vez te
sorprenda lo mucho que la geografía te
puede ayudar a evitar el fin me refiero
a analizar el mundo a tu alrededor
un concepto geográfico que te podría
ayudar en un apocalipsis es el
movimiento migratorio primero que emigra
las personas y los animales y aunque
lentamente los zombies también pero eso
no es todo los bienes se desplazan
también recursos como reservas de
alimentos y de armas y se desplazan
gracias a las personas o los zombis así
si ves un montón de reservas para zombis
donde antes no había estás sobre la
pista las ideas también se trasladan
como películas de zombies noticias e
información sobre ataques de zombies y
arquitectura o cómo construir un refugio
seguro segundo porque se traslada en las
personas o los zombies
este movimiento se llama migración los
factores de repulsión y de atracción
afectan la migración los
repulsión harán que quieras irte de un
sitio los de atracción hacen que quieras
ir a él una falta de recursos una mala
economía o mucha delincuencia pueden ser
factores de repulsión que hagan que la
gente quiera emigrar el buen clima una
buena economía o muchos recursos podrían
ser factores de atracción para muchos
los zombis son un factor de repulsión
para los humanos y una ciudad llena de
gente sería un factor de atracción para
los zombies hambrientos hay algunas
cosas que hacen el traslado más fácil
para las personas o los zombis los
canales y carreteras facilitan los
viajes un espacio abierto es más fácil
que uno agreste la tierra puede crear
fronteras que afectan a la migración y
también pueden hacerlo las fronteras
políticas como puedes analizar estos
factores de inmigración para sobrevivir
con tres pasos básicos primero
identificar los lugares a analizar
cuáles son tus opciones segundo buscar
lo que los conecta hay carreteras
canales o terreno abierto
y tercero buscar los patrones de
traslado que suceden en esa conexión hay
movimiento de personas o bienes al
comparar la relación entre lugares
podemos ver las conexiones que tienen
por ejemplo elige dos ciudades mira la
carretera que las conecta si la gente la
utiliza para ir al trabajo esas ciudades
tienen una relación fuerte esta ciudad
no tiene una conexión directa con las
otras ciudades hasta hay un río en el
camino no tiene una relación fuerte si
ocurriera un brote de zombis en qué
ciudad preferirías estar a dónde irías
entonces como decides a dónde ir en un
apocalipsis zombie simplemente corres en
una dirección arbitraria o utilizas tus
destrezas geográficas para guiar a los
supervivientes a un lugar seguro si
quiere seguir vivo ayuda al comprender
cómo y por qué nos trasladamos